EU leaders have elected Poland's Prime
Minister Donald Tusk as the next
president of the european council and
appointed italy's foreign minister
federica mogherini as the new High
Representative at an extraordinary
meeting in Brussels attended by
ukrainian President Petro poroshenko the
leaders also discussed plans for
possible new sanctions against Russia
for escalating the conflict in eastern
Ukraine to school take over the job of
chairing the european council from the
incumbent herman van rompuy on the first
of december his mandate will run for two
and a half years but can be renewed once
mogherini set to become the new face of
EU foreign affairs after the current
European Commission's mandate expires at
the end of October turning to the
conflict in Ukraine the leaders ordered
the Commission and the diplomatic
external action service to prepare
possible new sanctions against Russia
the European Council says says that it
stands ready to take further significant
steps in the light of the evolution of
the situation on the ground and it
requests the Commission to urgently
undertake preparatory work together with
the action surface and present proposals
for consideration we then within a week
the EU's already introduced measures
such as travel bans and asset freezes on
certain individuals and steps to target
banks arms and energy
you